in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Jason
and Joanna are with us hey guys how are
you Dave how are you welcome to
Nashville I'm better than I deserve
where are you from Plano Texas near
Dallas absolutely just a little north
fun to have you so you're here to do
your debt-free scream yep how much have
you paid off $65,000 very cool on how
long did that take about fifty four
months good and your range of income we
were making between 96 and 130 mm cool
what do you guys do for a living I'm a
technical writer and I'm a science
coordinator for a public school very
cool good for you guys so what kind of
debt was the 65,000 that was our
mortgage you paid off your house where
people I love it
well congratulations you guys aren't old
enough to have a paid-for house maybe
but I guess you are how old are you I'm
35 I just turned 38 Wow not even 40
years old your house is paid for what
sounds worth about 300,000 that is so
awesome what made you think you should
do this and could do this well so in
2006 I discovered this radio show and
that was kind of the the starting point
of our 10-year journey and Joanna and I
finally got on the same page about money
I was the spender and she was the saver
and so it was like we could talk the
same language now and so we just set a
goal that we really wanted to save up a
good down payment for a house which we
were able to do in 54 months ago we
actually bought the house and so we got
it paid off in that amount of time in
the last 11 months we actually cash
floated about 36,000 towards it so very
very well done well you guys are
absolutely incredible this is I I'm so
proud of a very good job good job so
what do you tell people the secret to
getting out of debt is for me the secret
was us getting on the same page honestly
if we hadn't started speaking the same
language if we hadn't set our goals and
from that setting our budget there's no
way we would have been able to
accomplish this Wow
good for you so how long have you been
married 13 years okay and so this made
you do things you've never done
communication wise in terms of working
with each other yeah pretty much that's
well this laser-focused together and you
know beating the snot out of this thing
so how does it feel to not even be 40
and have your house paid for um it's
pretty cool it's it's really awesome
when was the light when did you pay it
off so it was actually April was when we
say on the last check so you actually
had a couple months of enjoying this
yeah actually it's funny because we sent
the check in towards the end of the
month and they ended up taking out
another mortgage payment the next month
so we're like that's kind of crazy so we
actually only had a you know a couple of
months to enjoy it okay they got it yeah
I guess you got that back eventually
they refunded unbelievable Wow they just
never go away you can't make them get
out you can't get rid of them something
else very cool very cool well you guys
what was the hardest part of this for
y'all I think the hardest part for me
was just being persistent so you know we
first got the house we we wanted to kind
of take a breath and and then you know
eventually we kind of looked at each
other we're like okay so we've had a
little bit of time like we can really go
ahead and take care of this we'd gotten
a 15-year mortgage and we had plan to
get it paid off and you know seven years
by making some extra payments and we're
like you know what that's ridiculous
let's just go ahead and take care of it
I am so lonely I think the hardest part
for me was the seven years before we've
got the mortgage we were living in a
one-bedroom apartment for seven years
and he was a teacher and so we were just
trying to make ends meet and save some
money when we could very good yeah
absolutely
well congratulations you guys we're
gonna give you a signed copy of Chris
Mogens number one bestseller retire
inspired because that's the next chapter
now is to build wealth and be incredibly
outrageously generous and you'll be in
the place to do that because I mean
you're starting so early you're gonna
have so much money it's gonna be
unbelievable you just know it because
you've learned how to handle it you've
learned how to work together and if
money will always be something that you
control from now on there'll never be
something that controls you from now on
I'm so proud of you congratulations all
right it's Jason and Joanna Dallas Texas
65
thousand dollars paid off that's the
mortgage on their $300,000 home they did
it in 54 months making 96 to 132 you
heard the story count it down
let's hear a debt free scream three two
one weird
very well done that is just straight-up
awesomeness proud of you guys that's
very cool hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you can do this you
know that really is a message whether
you've got two hundred seventy thousand
dollars in student loan debt or 27
thousand well you've got a fifty
thousand dollar income or $500,000
income